مائير حبيب نائب برلماني فرنسي اسرائيلي
يعرف بصوت اسرائيل داخل فرنسا هي صفه
اطلقها الاعلام الفرنسي عليه بسبب علاقته
الوطيده ببنيامين نتنياهو ويعد مائير حبيب
شخصيه مثيره للجدل في فرنسا حيث تصدر
عناوين الصحفي هذا الاسبوع بعد تعليق له
في البرلمان الفرنسي بشان غزه فخلال
مداخله لرئيس لجنه الماليه في البرلمان
النائب عن فرنسا الابيه ايريك كوكال التي
ندد فيها بجرائم الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في
فلسطين وقتل الاف الشهداء في غزه قطعه
ماير بالقول لم ينتهي الامر
بعد اذا رفع بعد ذلك 39 نائبا من حركه
فرنسا الابيه لائحه الى رئيسه البرلمان
وذلك من اجل مباشره اجراءات لمعاقبه
النائب مائير حبيب بتهم تمجيد وتبرير
جرائم الحرب المرتكبه في قطاع غزه رئيسه
البرلمان الفرنسي يائيل بيف رفضت رفع
الحصانه عن النائب حبيب وقالت اللائحه
التي قدمها نواب من فرنسا الابيه وتحالف
اليسار لرفع الحصانه عن النائب مائير حبيب
غيره قانونيه لان الوحيده القادره على
تحريك دعوه لرفع الحصانه هو النائب العام
ايضا النائبه عن فرنسا الابليه فرانشيسكا
باكوين عبر حسابها على منصه اكس قالت هنا
رئيسه البرلمان لم تكن دقيقه خلال ردها
على اللائحه ولم تقم بادانه التصريحات
المشينه وغير المقبوله ل مائير حبيب قبل
ايام فرضت رئيسه البرلمان الفرنسي عقوبات
على نواب من فرنسا الابيه احتجوا على
قانون الهجره الجديده برفع لافتات وتمت
معاقبه النائب عن الحزب ذاته انتوني ولمون
بسبب وصفه نواب الحزب التجمع الوطني
بالنازيه اذا تفاعل كبير مع رفض رئيسه
البرلمان الفرنسي معاقبه حبيب دعونا نبدا
هنا
برينا تقول هنا هذا الرجل ندفع له اموالنا
ليتحدث باسم الصهاينه تحت قبه البرلماني
له من عار حقيقي لم يفتح فمه للحديث عن
الفضائح الاسرائيليه لكنه لا يتردد في
اتهام زملائه بالارهاب نصل ايضا الى حساب
نيلز يقول حجتها تتعارض مع العقوبه
المتخذه ضد النائب توماس بورت بفضل حيله
اجرائيه كان من الممكن تطبيقها على مائير
حبيب ازدواجيه المعايير صادمه ماذا عن
توماس بورت طبعا توماس بورت هو النائب
طبعا نائب في فرنسا يقول المؤيدون غير
المشروط لمجرمي الحرب الاسرائيليين يحمون
بعضهم البعض وهنا يستطيع عضو البرلمان
الفرنسي ان يبرر بهدوء جرائم الحرب يا
للعار اخيرا نصل معكم الى الى عز الدين
يقول رئيسه البرلمان تسارع لانقاذ الجندي
مائير حبيب ولكن الى متى سيفلت هذا
المتطرف من العقاب لم ينتهي بعد مائير
حبيب ينجو من رفع الحصانه النيابيه بعد
تبريره لجرائم الحرب اذا مائير حبيب رد
على المطالبات بفرض عقوبات عليه قائلا اصر
على قولي لم ينتهي الامر ستقضي اسرائيل
على حماس وانا ادين التلاعب الصارخ الذي
قام به هؤلاء النواب خطوتهم هذه هي محاوله
للتغطيه على تمجيده للارهاب وانكار لمعدات
الساميه